[Music]
I'm your Ghost of Christmas presents
Like A Christmas Carol
[Music]
on a bitter cold Christmas Eve one Dark
Soul is selected for Redemption by the
ghosts of Christmas past present and yet
to come a tradition that continues
through this very Night
Like A Christmas Carol yes yes if you
would just let me get this outfit so out
of all the people on the planet
murderers people who do gender reveal
parties I'm the guy you're gonna hunt
you know what forget it
I told you the guy is a level 20 pain in
the Dickens come on I can take this guy
I'm your Ghost of Christmas present
I'm not watching your dramatic
re-encrapment hey I'm haunting you you
can't just run away from me but I'm
haunting you hello
I believe he can be a positive force for
mankind and he's got his hands all over
everything yeah I wish Mom are you
texting HR no
people don't sing We got a runner
that's just fun to watch
I'm here to change into being a more
positive force for Humanity
[Laughter]
[Music]
you photoshop yourself into these
pictures of my executive VP thanks so oh
you want that what I want is for you to
shut up and let me do my job is there a
Ghost of Christmas grumpy because you
could do that job
[Music]
is where real change begins
Oh that's oh he's dead yeah he's
definitely no no he's fine he's good
well I'm not a burial anyway
[Music]
I know that change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
[Applause]
[Music]
let's start our new life
[Music]
does anyone in Andalusia ever just say
stuff not if we can help it
this world feels very different is it
sometimes easier to live in andalasia
well I wouldn't say easier we have
dragons and ogre rebellions last year
the entire kingdom was trapped in a
giant whale oh this is not a magic land
it is a land far far away from my
friends
I'm so late I'm a commuter now you're
riding this train over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
then you die
as you can see Giselle everyone has
their place once you've found where you
fit Monroeville can be whatever you wish
I wish for a fairy tale life remember
happily ever after it's not always that
easy
my hair it's so high and my dress is so
low Jumping Jelly sticks we got magic
town is turning into a very tale thing
but it's all gone terribly wrong I'm the
last stroke of midnight
nothing will be as it was before
an unevil cat I'm not an evil cat I'm
not an evil cat what is going on you
need to remember your place here Mr
mother please
[Music]
is it under a curse we have to stop this
or everything animation will die there's
no one wishing your wish now Giselle
come on time to be heroes
no there's only room for one villain in
this town
you're hilarious
delusional but hilarious
I'm sorry I think your things are in my
seat I'm sorry
oh come on you've got to be kidding me
excuse me ma'am I need to sit somewhere
else we used to be married worse 19
years of my life we were only married
for five I'm counting the recovery
in four days time our daughter's gonna
marry a guy she just met ooh Bali
millions of miles from home I just
really want to kiss you it's like I
looked up for the first time and
realized everything I ever wanted was
right in front of me she's throwing her
career away just like her mother did so
I'm the only one who can stop her she
doesn't listen to him champagne oh two
please just leave the bottle thank you
[Applause]
I won't let her throw her life away we
need to trick her into dumping him as
much as this will pain us both we have
to call a truce to make this work you're
being lockstep
hey did you make a pact to not murder
each other until you murdered me first
we are here for you my love yes we're in
the last step yes
promise no mean comments pretty sure you
don't win anything for eating the whole
pig no arguing
no passive aggression what about
aggressive aggression try to keep it
snoring down I have a nasal strip it's a
mystery you're still alone
Mom Dad this is good day
you learned that to make me look bad you
don't need my help there
are you sure they're not sharks come on
don't be a chicken you might be working
with the sharks come on
can't believe I got bit by a dolphin he
said pressure
so what's the plan I say we steal the
Rings
how they look it's acquainted
go wrong we're not wrong who are we to
say that Lily doesn't know what's best
for herself
[Music]
you cannot believe you what are you
talking about about she found the Rings
Where in Mom's bag I knew it what
you clean up pretty good
there you go it's not for the faint of
heart this is not his first rodeo
okay let's go let's go can we get
something a little more age-appropriate
for these two here we go which one
there's only one I see two
oh yeah
[Music]
oh no no Dad please stop doing that oh
my God
I'm praying for an asteroid
honey maybe we should just call it a
night you go ahead I gotta finish these
center pieces and rearrange the seating
chart
yes
hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like Pilates
we got your gift it's your Something
Borrowed brings you good luck except for
Uncle Greg who ended up decapitated on
that forklift but that's not the knives
fall oh someone just left that in the
bathroom
you forgot to put his shirt all the way
up
is it time for dinner
you look so much better than the rest of
us I think the left boom is slightly
lower than the right food something
doesn't feel right
[Applause]
here's the plan
spray him in the ice it won't work why
so many steps
white you only have a plan with once
not once did I wonder if I'd be walking
Hancock Through the Jungle with a live
grenade
oh you got it I got it you got it okay
[Music]
had just grown on me I wanted something
less traditional
nobody with my family
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Carol thank you for the cake knife
foreign
super fun
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa where
yes you
sure
[Music]
[Music]
come on get your lazy ass up
already that's what you get staying out
partying all night I'm a promoter I'm
working I got like 18 000 followers you
know who got followers Jesus take your
rude ass to work you just cursed what
would Jesus say Jesus will say shut the
[ __ ] up this is my house
see you later you need to clean this
place
oh that counts just loved itself whose
crib is this man Steve Jobs Steve Jobs
is dead fool I mean his house died
[Music]
dude got Miami [ __ ] Cleveland [ __ ] La
[ __ ] damn bigger city bro
oh my God we in LeBron's house LeBron
who James hey there oh you're a one
handsome [ __ ] he got a hologram
of himself just to give him compliments
you handled the decision to go to Miami
perfectly nah that's cap
I need 10 G's by next week I gotta pay
for my daughter's school they on
vacation how about we throw the party in
the King's house we gonna invite all the
celebrities we can make 10 times the
money we can send Destiny to preschool
College whatever tonight is our last
shot looks like me
hi I see you there how are you oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm going to jail hi I'm Peter
is LeBron home
um by the way
black lives matter they do I posted two
squares on my Instagram respect
[Music]
I wouldn't do something like this unless
I was desperate
cracking bro
[Music]
I see how out of control this party is
[ __ ] we done [ __ ] up the koala
you good what the [ __ ] just happened
your hairline is perfect anyone who says
otherwise is just jealous this guy
[Music]
though no don't you dare let that little
rat dog piss on my walkway again ignore
him Prince he has no idea who's doing
that well it was one of you
get out of here
you cannot use this road without a
permit have a nice day sir you know the
other guys don't do this guys with the
white trucks how come it's always you
brown guys and I don't mean that
racially
I'm sorry you didn't get me earlier the
whole neighborhood has fallen apart
these days
[Music]
oh my God give me the keys
hello hello what's your name Otto Otto
Otto I'm Abby o-t-t-o
got some new neighbors right an Edward
husband
I brought you some food okay bye
are you always this unfriendly I am not
unfriendly okay you're not every word
you say is like a warm cuddle
[Music]
can you please give me a ride I don't
have a license you don't have a driver's
license how old are you
[Music]
a hybrid
[Music]
how did you get in here no no no you are
not taking over my bed
I was wondering if you could help us out
[Music]
I think you have to do everything on
your own guess what no one can
you want to see a trick yeah if I borrow
a coin what are you doing
it was all the Clown's fault
[Music]
foreign
are you ready what are we doing
we're gonna run for our lives
we're halfway home halfway I'm chicky
Donahue and I am not supposed to be in
Vietnam
hey get your ass out of bed you lazy bum
look at you sleep in your life away look
at these scumbags you're embarrassing
yourself if you're embarrassing your
family these protesters not know that
our soldiers see that on TV I'd like to
go over to Vietnam track down all the
boys in the neighborhood and give them a
beer I could do that do what bringing
beer he's not serious he's hammered look
at him the man stoned sober that's his
fifth beer maybe tops I'm going to
Vietnam and I'm bringing a beer
hey chief no chance you have a ship
heading to Vietnam 1700 hours tonight
it's not gonna be easy but I'm gonna
show them that this country is still
behind him you're gonna get yourself
killed over there it's like you said
everyone's doing something I'm doing
nothing
I'm smuggling beer into a war zone
that's not the smartest thing I've ever
heard of certainly not the worst either
what if you start up here with Collins
this came to the sudsy thank you card
and then if you're still alive
you American New York thanks a lot you
can hustle down to Dugan
[Applause]
I bring you beer you shouldn't be here
you think this is funny I'm not doing
this for Laughs I'm doing it for all you
guys
come on time to go
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't get it do you chick this isn't
a John Wayne movie but you know the good
guys are on you know the bad guys are
[Music]
let me come all this way just to quit
somebody's got to be here see what's
going on
I want the truth told for them they're
just kids you're gonna find out it's a
lot harder to get out of a war than it
is to get into one I'm trying to show
them that somebody back home is still
behind them
you got a good heart chicky your brains
I'm worried about
who's this hand job it's my next-door
neighbor he brought me a beer
all right
[Music]
did my daughter Eloise come she left a
note for you you can just read it
ourselves dear Mom I know some pool all
I've ever wanted was to feel like a part
of this family but I thought maybe my
wedding would be a chance to reconnect
I see now that maybe we were never
really connected
oh my God have you seen this invitation
are you going to the wedding Eloise is
our half sister which means we can
half-ass the relationship
my rich sister chose to stay in London
and shove fish and chips up her butt
that's not how you eat them
is my company upgraded me very cool
country mouse I figured that everyone in
business class was going to be hot and
mean like you they got Paddington on
this flight
stink
[Music]
it starts the worst thank you thank you
for coming to England my nuptials she's
like netaporte and I'm like Nordstrom
Rack Alice the wine is spilling you bet
it is Mom sounds like a monster so
lovely having you all here only 72 hours
until the big guy too
what Alice
Alice I think I just had some bad
chicken I have any chicken
it's wonderful being here with my
children and all their friends you know
he's not my friend you know I support
you Excuse me yes sir yes he's my son
what's happening and they do sex things
it's a-okay with me and I'm proud
I'm getting married
from this moment forward you will behave
like a normal family who is here to
happily celebrate a loved one's wedding
is that understood she's even prettier
when she's angry absolutely radiant
[Music]
all right
do you think this is funny I do you know
how at every wedding there are those
people everyone talk about after cousin
Randy oh who are those people this time
oh Savage mom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that is but a taste of our Fury
do you yield
I do not
I finally found it now who's gonna stop
me
foreign
what is this place
do not touch that mushroom you'll die oh
I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine come
on Mario
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I perform oral sex on you number two you
perform oral sex on me number three we
do a 69 if that's what it's still called
um four me on top five doggy style that
all sounds very achievable if I booked
enough time you you want to do it all
today you
there are nuns out there with more
sexual experience that means
embarrassing get me to brush my teeth oh
God this is crazy it's terrible it's
wrong Nancy yes come have a dance at me
[Music]
I got some frustrated clear ground your
real name
now I simply don't understand why you're
doing this
yes disabled for a college oh wow
wonderful are you really no
oh
I've always been ashamed of my body your
body's beautiful I wish you could see
that
everyone wants something different I
don't judge my clients that's their
total rehearsals
I've never done anything interesting in
my life
[Music]
what's the oldest person you've ever
done it with 82 82 yes 82. Nancy okay
I'm feeling a bit better now
[Music]
so is this Runway casting for a grumpy
brand or a smiley brand
so it's a grumpy brand yeah
congratulations show me that Balenciaga
look
suddenly I'm dressed in something way
less expensive
h m yeah
thanks for the tickets not better that's
what do you do I sell [ __ ]
the success of a luxury Cruise mainly
depends on you
I don't want to hear anybody saying no
[Music]
it's always yes sir yes ma'am
I'm on you enjoy the moment
no no no what
you say no to me no no so it's yes yeah
no yes oh yeah yes
the saves you think it's possible to
wash them
I don't think that's possible man
because this is a motorized vessel yeah
so we don't have any sales
it was safe yes
well then in that case
we will clean the sales yes of course
yes
[Music]
Russian capitalists
and an American Communist on a 250
million dollar luxury
hey hey
the ship is going under
[Music]
this is really bad
this is really really bad
foreign
middle child two brothers were actually
very close but they live in different
states only child childhood obsessions
Christmas magic
my name is Michael you're a great dancer
you're a terrible liar and that's kid
I've always imagined that my life was
like a typical romantic comedy you were
so confident and you just ripped off
your clothes like your strippered a
bachelorette party and I basically
shower with clothes on
don't just shut up now shall we go to
your place tonight there's my door
before we go in just open the door okay
what is this Michael oh you don't want
to oh my God they're in here too
I think you're very cool and I'm worried
that you're going to break my heart you
know I'm mad this is my friend Mike a
friend yes Mom just a friend what is
going on here who is this guy he's my
boyfriend your boyfriend I think it's a
great kid we may not look like it but we
are actually kind of hip oh my God we
were gonna go to Woodstock you know
I am let's just take a moment to
appreciate this beauty
get what is going on are you all right
come down off the ledge Mike I'm seeing
a doctor tomorrow
I'm afraid the news isn't good
I was always afraid kit would break my
heart and eventually he did he broke it
open
yeah
you have to run the race in front of you
because that's all there is look back
this is less of a rom-com and more of
the love story you can't sit for four
hours we've promised bed all the beds
are occupied give my husband a bed well
that was Oscar worthy worked for Shirley
McLean
I'm sorry I never told you how good your
ass looks in your khaki pants I was
afraid if you understood how beautiful
you are if you could leave me thank you
for inviting us it was Kiss idea I was
vehemently opposed to it
and like all love stories it never
actually ends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Sheila hi hi I'm uh I'm Gary
gonna get here
thank you
cheers mate
that was kind of weird no not really
Do You Love Me Tomorrow
I have got to come clean with you I'm
from the future
wait I'm I'm sorry I'm a little confused
so how much do you use the tanning
machine oh no it's not a tan machine
it's a time machine try it it's fun I've
spent the entire week with you this
night seven times in a row
[Music]
wait what'd you do with the other youth
from the past
oh
do you think I'm crazy
but it's really cute
Have You Ever Had A Night Like This ever
in your entire life I just wanted to
change a couple things to make you more
perfect this never happened with old
Gary if you erase the pain you erase the
person what exactly did you change about
me I have this ability to take your pain
away it's not yours to take away Sheila
it came from a good place Gary yeah so
did gender reveal parties
I am gonna make it work
a real Sophie's Choice kind of decision
now isn't it I love it when you make
that joke what what
[Applause]
[Music]
you didn't want to go somewhere more
meaningful like I don't know like to
kill Hitler well I did take out Smithson
who
won it's Bobby Lieber and welcome to
your favorite podcast where I talk about
whatever I feel like talking about
so these big movie Producers came to me
and said we want you to write a rom-com
about a gay couple
something a straight guy might even like
and watch with his girlfriend gay guys
are my jam awesome something a straight
guy might like am I gonna be in the
middle of some high-speed chase then all
of a sudden fall in love with Ice Cube
am I gonna get butt [ __ ] by Jason
Momoa while we're both worrying about a
volcano
they said we just want a movie that
shows shows a world that gay
relationship straight relationships are
the same
Love Love Is Love Is Love No it's not
that is [ __ ]
our friendships are different I have to
go to a party they're too old to be in
the pool please leave our sex lives are
different ass pick don't have ass pick
must see pic of ass
took this just for you bro
did he block me our relationships are
different this is bisexual awareness
week and no one has acknowledged it
lesbian history month was in March
nobody said a goddamn thing of course
lesbians get a month and we get a week I
don't
I don't [ __ ] no scenes where two
guys are about to hook up and all of a
sudden the camera conveniently pulls
away
oh hey I'm gonna go this is nice meeting
you yeah YouTube is lovely
[Music]
my whole life I prided myself on being
self-reliant
what is going on with you this
[ __ ] has gone into my head
what are you into one of these [ __ ]
ripped idiots with no opinion no I'd
like someone who's physically very frail
and won't stop talking
maybe you both bottomed and that's a
problem
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god gay sex was more fun when
straight people were uncomfortable with
it
anyway it doesn't matter I'm not the
right person to write a rom-com anyway
oh my god do you guys remember straight
people yeah they had a nice run
[Music]
you can't be here
one more move and you get an eye full of
pepper it's me
I grew up always feeling like I was an
older woman trapped in the body of a
little girl I wrote a book if you're
getting paid for something it's a hobby
and hobbies are disgusting and I did my
darndest to keep my inner old gal to
myself
I thought it would be super fun if we
all lie down and do that Half-Life
progression what you should go do it
we'll just meet back up at the house
and think about who you want to be
oh oh my God
so we're thinking about old lady stuff
and he turned into one so he should be
able to turn you back into you where did
he go
we're never gonna find him Matt coming
coming are you sick you sound weird no
buddy well hello I'm Max Aunt Rita I'm
Jack I'll take care of cheese when max
out of town
this is Max on tirida how often do you
ladies meet for your wine club every day
sometimes we spend the weekend how are
we supposed to grow old on the French
Riviera if you're 50 years ahead of me
Matt you are scheduled to cover the
Pilates events post pictures
and let's reset
you know these pocket computer photo
albums are my job these days I get paid
to post pictures
[Music]
that's happening for you right now
because you're showing the world who you
are we're getting some interesting
offers for Rita
post more of my glammy grammy people are
dying for her Rita you got a man well
this guy's young he's young man you
didn't want to be old what you wanted
was to be you
and when I came out I was in this body
okay you're coming in with a lot of
energy
[Music]
I banish thee from Salem forever
[Music]
they were right to fear thee
magic has a way of uniting
happy 16th birthday child
I have a gift from my favorite customers
Legend has it it's on the 16th birthday
that a witch gets her powers
Gilbert where did you get that candle we
have to get out of here the witch it'll
be here any seconds the book is alive he
woke up
if we intend to live past Sunrise we
have to steer this so whoa whoa wait can
we talk about this
Not freak out the provincial Maniac
obsessed with getting revenge on Salem
so
for sale
we should get some salt why so it tastes
better when they eat us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I blamed bad luck for everything that's
gone wrong in my life
[Music]
you sure have bad luck Sam Greenfield
take that universe
oh until
I found an actual Lucky Penny
something that could finally turn my
life around
and what did I do
I flushed it down the toilet
get flushed my panties in the toilet
you just talked
wait I just need another penny
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well done nature this is where good luck
is born a dragon she's the only creature
that can sniff out bad look there's bad
luck here too good luck on top bad luck
on the bottom the tiniest amount of bad
luck couldn't shut down our entire
operation
just how unlucky are you
oh no
look for duper unlucky you cause a
disaster
the good luck connection has been
severed I do you and everyone else to a
life of bad luck we need to fix this
what are you doing here
good luck to us both
what about Jeff unstyle yes
I have no words
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing thank you Spiderman
still need help
[Music]
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
[Music]
where
are we
gonna come down
[Music]
it's a secret Universe beneath ours
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you
[Music]
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
Deer Creek International Business
Solutions how can I help you I am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh I see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck really my bad
luck is biblical I'm not even trying to
kill people when someone dies remember
the suicidal billboard you drove him to
the hospital hang in there buddy and he
didn't die okay the wedding
Johannesburg it's time for some change
do you want it simple for your first job
back doesn't get something
[Music]
the twins yeah and I'm so sure they're
twins get off the train
[Music]
you stab me
I would never stuck on fire what
I missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man I've ever seen
really you don't remember me
[Music]
thanks lady I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm I'm
working on it get off at the next stop
it's not so sweet easy when you say it
it's one little pricker I'm missing you
know what happens yes your blood congest
yes
you're going to want to hear the whole
story the 24th and Kyoto the white death
with his army of Assassins there's this
solar psychotic leader with the largest
criminal organization on the planet
shoved right inside
I don't see the way death let in any
other stuff is training
we need to come up with a plan
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma Maybe
[Music]
it's
strange
[Music]
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
it's funny even though we haven't been
together that long I can't believe it's
only been three months it feels like
forever when you know you know
babe
from the moment that I saw your face
looking up at me Griffin save it for the
real proposal the real proposal
tomorrow night at our New Year's Eve
party
it's for the best
sister's wedding what am I going to do I
can't just pick up some random guy off
the street
here
I live at Norwood 15 Maple Drive you're
not in Norwood you're in Westwood what
this is crazy but my sister is getting
married and my ex was supposed to be my
plus one and I can't show up without a
date I really can't of course I mean I
sound psycho no no not at all
yes I'd have to leave by eight
hey Clem where are you that I had to
make a quick stop it's almost nine time
for pictures I'll be right over there
was that a bride more quick stop was at
a wedding
um
you're being crazy that's him right
there not much to look at but seems nice
I want to hear how YouTube Mets I guess
you could say I caught her by surprise
it's been a Non-Stop Adventure it's an
impressive speech most surprisingly
effortless
Margo Kip Kip I thought he was Camp well
don't look at me I have no idea but the
new Kip is hot
not the cake do you mess up the cake no
we're good
you like him so he's proposing to
someone else he doesn't love me if he's
so in love with her what's he doing at a
wedding with you
I'm sorry I felt something that I've
never felt before and I institute the
right thing you know when the universe
gives you a gift you don't just say no
call it Faith dumb luck or chance
but I still get to choose
[Music]
the science has closed let's break in
wait
are you crazy I'm bringing a stranger to
my sister's wedding
do I look like I make good decisions
under pressure
oh life moves fast one day you're
playing Kick the Can with kids named
flick and Schwartz
the next thing you know you're a
certified adult
Ralph dear old man
he was the best
grumpy promise me we're gonna make this
a wonderful Christmas that would make
your father so happy I promise
what had I done and that was all up to
me I suggest you start drinking and
don't stop till New Year's
[Music]
kids who wants to go see Santa what is
this amazing incredible we will meet you
right here when you're done don't let
him kick you in the face
decorating it kind of feels like child
labor honey it's not labor if we don't
pay you yeah
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
that's brutal
slowly I could feel the Christmas Ember
beginning to Glow again
[Music]
all right Frank where are you right now
none of your business come on Fletch
aren't you bored
what's the password go ask yourself
my father's paintings were stolen
Picasso was appraised at 20 million
dollars well it hardly seems worth
stealing you're not a detective but it
was an investigative reporter it's an
occupation that's been deepened by the
digital age like president
Earl Maurice Fletcher they caught me in
the middle of a yawn you imagine that
who killed this young woman I think the
victim interrupted an art theft
your fingerprints are on the murder
weapon and someone matching your
description was seen with the victim
come back with me to Police Headquarters
I get it
you want my help okay hey guys this is
the way we can call in a coffee or a
kill for a macchiato not literally I
looked into your criminal record and
you're a bit of a shady character Mr
Fletcher but I am adorable
if you did kill that girl do the right
thing and give me an exclusive let's
talk about the suspects
[Music]
somehow she's involved play she's trying
to seduce me
with a collection of the Christmas those
are reproductions that's how we
introduce my children
why did you lie to me you're becoming
paranoid maybe you should get a gun
she murdered that girl okay no I didn't
did you what is this
almost
[Music]
this stupid idiot [ __ ] has something to
do with this you want me on the outside
so I can solve this thing
are you Fletcher yes I am oh I mean no
I'm not I always get that wrong
I don't know what people hate more cops
are reporters
cops
the greatest love story ever told Romeo
sweet Juliet was missing a chapter
mine
get up you lazy cow I have cholera you
do not have cholera you don't understand
they were being all gross and he was
saying things to her that he just said
to me three days ago yes three nurse
so you're gonna break them up of course
I am Romeo and Juliet doesn't even sound
right you want my help with this we just
need to stop a wedding my boyfriend is
about to make the biggest mistake of his
life hang on a second it's your
boyfriend's wedding
ouch
blow me
Roslyn I met a boy let me guess Romeo
Montague isn't it everybody knows Romeo
Montague but Juliet if I settle down
with just one man when you can sample at
the buffet of Life who wants to buy us
some drinks
[Music]
the difference
I just wonder if all this drama
adding to the attraction I'm going to
fake my own death I'll drink this potion
it'll look like I'm dead that is quite
possibly the dumbest thing I've ever
heard in my life
[Music]
drink it already
I'm an idiot
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
Aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and Batman is so cool and I'm just
me
[Music]
I feel like a fraud it doesn't matter
um anyway a wizard gave me super powers
but then everybody got super powers
where's everyone going
to fight crime okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right
come on
[Music]
outfit of Your World depends on it
for you
[Music]
children stored the power of all the
gods
very
[Music]
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies Lady it's all about
family guys that was a signal
[Music]
the world will not survive this
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I think I know how to fix this dude but
I really don't really everyone can be
worthy let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]
kind of dating that finally Jesus stop
living in denial denial of what okay
you're living in dick denial
Island that Nina broke up and now
they're over there trying to see who
gets to stay a regular here we have
people write down challenges and whoever
wins gets to stay I'm an attorney I
fight for a living bring it
[Applause]
[Music]
human bowling nice choice
[Applause]
oh
that's what you get
you need to kill anyone
she's like a Mary Poppins from hell
[Applause]
[Music]
he's catching up over here from toss it
back trust me I was in a sorority I put
things in my throat all the time
[Music]
Danny yeah I had a chance to read that
article you sent me what'd you think you
don't feel like it comes off a little
tone deaf offensive even I don't feel
like you take me seriously as a writer
that's because you're not a writer
you're a photo editor
have you ever wanted to be noticed so
badly hey Mom you wanna hang out tonight
[Music]
I care what it was for all
oh [ __ ] what up honey Danny Danny from
work Danny go College I love your videos
Man
thanks B so what are you I'm a writer
I'm looking to develop my work by
traveling
going to Paris for it
[ __ ] hey get picked I'm gonna get lots
of pics yeah I'll throw them all up on
the gram right
[ __ ]
hey Mom I got invited to a writer's
retreat in Paris yes really starting my
morning right now where's my baguette
[Music]
we have some breaking news at this hour
a string of terrorist attacks dropped
Paris this morning leaving dozens dead
and many more injured
oh
[ __ ] it's like 26.77 now run Danny she's
okay
we are here with the girl of the moment
you've been blowing up our insta feet
speaking of bombings I'm really glad
you're not good me too
isn't she so strong everybody
[Applause]
oh my God you're the girl from the Paris
attack let's not forget the signature
red beret
hi I'm Danny Rowan welcome to group
we're all survivors here do you want to
share
you're not okay that's okay
the internet likes to turn victims into
villains
those seem to be happening to me
paired if it does
we need to talk
careful what you [ __ ] wish for
so what are we supposed to feel bad for
you
the victim's name is Leo copernic sir
seems he's killed in the costume story
[Music]
and then he was deposited here
staged so to speak
how much longer do you intend to hold at
all hostage or is that the idea gather
all the suspects and interrogate each of
us in turn until the mystery Soul Marvin
cochranaris overrated playwright
celebrated clear right oh I'm so sorry
sir I can't read me on hand right
[Music]
there was an incident
I'll kill you this good is a confession
it's not jumps and conclusions
what do we have here it's working late
huh
he kills copernic to hush up the affair
case close I'm doing it again aren't you
sir
a real life detective I understand that
you came to blows tonight in question
it was me inspector I arrest you for the
murder of Leo Cocker no we have a serial
killer on the loose
[Music]
the key
under the mat
we are no longer merely suspects
we are awesome
potential victims
so what did he do that made you
suspicious it wasn't so much what he did
it was more the way he did it hardly do
it
suspiciously right
we are gonna have the most peaceful
Christmas this year
who is this we need to call an emergency
Sisters Meeting what is the Christmas
family done now it's Dad it's appeared
dad has made several payments from a
hotel in Nevis in the Caribbean five
book tickets for the three of us we're
going to the Caribbean this afternoon
what you might want to start packing
flight leaves at four
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
can a man disappear without being hunted
down by his nosy daughters AI I'm here
to rescue you Daddy I want you to go
back to your families why are you just a
little bit happy to see us Dad I am
staying here I think Dad is having a
massive emotional reaction well well
Jake aren't you full of surprised
another wonderful day the three of us
have to do everything we possibly can
and we have to convince him to come back
to England with us you three look like
you're up to no good
[Music]
be careful they're dangerous and
addictive we're gonna need some more
Killer Bees Joanna
morning I hate you
family need to stick together
agreed
agreed
[Music]
I feel a lot of change coming on James
dad wants to have fun he should have fun
who are you and what have you done with
Joanna
[Music]
very moment I am on a Caribbean island
with three of my magnificent four
daughters and I couldn't be happier
when I go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I just want to clarify some things
before we
before we get started every woman is not
built for the great responsibility of
being a first lady Pastor Lee Curtis
Childs faces allegations of misconduct
his mega church may never be the same
leak Curtis and I we're gonna get to the
other side
you know with the big old microphone
come in closer son you're gonna see what
all the fuss is about
that's just our turn baby Lee Curtis is
a talent a star oh boy uh we can edit
around that right this is going to
Chronicle the ultimate comeback I'm
Rocky up in this fight
Rocky didn't win but he did win in Rocky
too
how many times I gotta you get past the
first movie that was all set up
he is just so wrong
he needs someone to harness it all
I bless your heart I'm sure plenty of
the old congregation will come right on
back through good old ones of the
greater path to us
you have a blessed one oh my goodness
and you have a blessed
I'm a center [ __ ] I'm no criminal we
need you back in that Pulpit so you can
get me back on that stage baby
take it for the Lord
[Music]
[Applause]
all those folks out there who are gonna
see this I want them to know
and I did what I was supposed to do
I just don't see how that's possible all
things are possible with God that's
Matthew 19 20. yes it is
so that's good you can cut
[Music]
in theaters and streaming only on
peacock September 2nd
you're not here yet father's play a big
role in their daughter's life
it's a special bond that only they share
hello
and even when she's all grown up she's
still Daddy's Little Girl
[Music]
I have something to say I'm engaged
and I propose
okay you propose yes you propose to him
he didn't propose to you can you do that
does anyone do that you both have been
coming here for over a year do you still
want this marriage to work or not
I'm here no
it was to play the perfect family until
Sophie gets married well we can say
sorry to spoil your happiness but we're
getting at the force muscle tough mommy
Papi this is we don't want some big
fancy wedding and we want to pay for it
the lawyers are out of college working
for a non-profit is going to pay for the
wedding really I'm the father of the
bride and I would be paying for the
wedding and I'm going to be walking my
daughter down the aisle the wedding
party in 20 minutes left Amelia so what
are we thinking about being okay we
don't want a Catholic wedding what are
you talking about you're gonna officiate
them my guide Monica from the Zen Center
New York so yoga class is set up a
wedding hi karamba
this is my father for the wedding oh my
God how rich is this guy
what is your bond villain
we should go for the ground rules can we
hold hands We Can Can we dance if
necessary about a kiss absolutely not
Daddy what is the budget that we're
working with how about dick
yes I really like him he's Nothing Like
Us maybe that's the point we don't watch
sports no you play sports I like hiking
things have been coming at me very fast
it's time for me to embrace the future I
got your butt show time baby
now we're back
[Applause]
[Music]
ready yes and you
no
[Music]
foreign
if I say that you shall be married then
married you should be
where is the lady Catherine that come
here to propose marriage the man has
come and asked me by name you cannot
mean our lady she's a vile creature some
say she has a third ear she does have
you seen this 30th I've seen it where
back of her neck is it functional I'm
interested in meeting him or any man
with his intentions
to die rather than be forced to marry I
do not think either option appealing
I cheer for you buddy
I am thankful Lord very cunning most
girls are that we're not giving you
credit for it I do think she's come down
the Sun and she's got a little little um
little little little bit of I think
there's a little bit of pox going around
them
it's
only a small little box
es creatures
what is close to my face you have wings
you must learn how to harness them
you'll get to decide who we are where we
go or how much we cost like we're just
things we're not things we're people and
we can think and we can hear and we can
feel
[Music]
I wish I could help every girl in the
world
[Music]
but for now
I am enough
friends
foreign
[Music]
that's how we did it in the 90s son
Can't Catch My Breath man really should
I try math stuff what is this a Tinder
date get off of me oh [ __ ] Mr Dante I
need an enemy inside the Quick Stop
saved my life man I wish I had a life
worth saving what are you talking about
just sit around and watch the same
movies over and over I always thought
you could have made a cool movie you're
right I'm living on borrowed time no
more watching movies I'm gonna make a
movie
what's the movie gonna be about it's
about him working here met up everything
in this script is something either me or
someone I know said I'm not even
supposed to be here today maybe Jane
Silent Bob could be characters okay and
Silent bobbert like C-3PO and R2D2
they've been here since the first movie
which was the last time they were cool
but they've been with the franchise so
long they still give them cameos and put
them on the lunch boxes Snoopy
[Music]
it's sued by Disney
take off your pants
uh what the hell is this I added a scene
where you get shot I'm not letting you
kill me off in the third act what if
there's a sequel a sequel what am I a
hack
I think it needs more weed
okay time to go you can't leave me and
Rodrick alone together for a whole
weekend don't forget to unload the
dishwasher
I can teach you lots of things little
brothers I call it my rod Rick rolls
don't you mean roderick's rules Roger
curl number one no apostrophes or any
other nerd stuff
[Applause]
it's party time
so what's rule number two you only get
one roll a week that's logic rule number
two that's not fair rule number three
life's not fair and now you made me
break rule number two uh
roderick's been taking me under his wing
been teaching me a bunch of stuff what
kind of stuff
I've got potential
[Music]
me and you're gonna have our battles
but when the chips are down don't let
him get away I'm gonna have your back
and you better have mine
you look like you wet yourself
all right it's nasty
girl number 10 always go out in a blaze
of glory Susan
oh you see I can't unsee that
[Music]
our father is dead his last wish was
that his sons attend his funeral we're
interested go he's dead
he'll never know you're a very tender
man you know that
okay your father's last will it was his
wish that you dig his grave
what
the old man was always screwing with us
but forgiveness is good
I want to show you the casket that your
father pre-selected
the cheapest man who ever lived
hi how did you know our father we were
lovers for a while
what was he like as a father the worst
like a weight on my chest
forgiveness is good
hi guys this is my son Simon Raymond I'm
Ray
your brothers
hello hey
we come from chaos
our father was a monster and we repeat
we repeat
we don't have to
[Music]
go
growing up my brother and I we were
connected to him
and then just being near each other as a
reminder of all that pain
I want to know what it feels like
letting it go
but I'm scared it's going to crush me
come with me
[Music]
but it's gonna take a whole lot more
than a hole in the ground to get the old
man out of your head
[Music]
[Music]
Sony Larry didn't you he used to be the
best of friends we're still the best of
friends no you're not who says we're not
is it somewhere else
now if I've done something to you just
tell me what I've done to you when you
didn't do happen to me I just don't like
you no more
like me yesterday
why does he not want to be friends with
you no more
why is he 12. what the hell is going on
with you me [ __ ] brother it's Donald
Siobhan but he's always been done to the
night two hours you spend talking to me
about the things you found in your
little donkey shite that day well it
wasn't me little donkey shows me Pony
shite which shows how much you were
listening foreign
and if you don't stop bothering me I
have a set of shears at home and each
time you bother me from this day on I'll
take those shears and I'll take one of
my fingers off with them and I'll give
that finger to you until I have no
fingers left does this make things
clearer to you not really no starting
from now but just like party you know
just like yeah
would you not want him to have to do one
finger to see if he was bluffing like no
we wouldn't because worse comes to worse
you can still play the fiddle with four
fingers I bet yeah going back to wrong
guys no party they're talking to me play
it
why aren't you talking to pouring no
more that wouldn't be a sin though would
have fun no but it's not very nice
either is it do you know who will
remember for how nice they was in the
17th century hope absolutely no one here
we all remember the music at the time
everyone to a man knows Mozart's name I
don't so there goes that theory
be waiting round for any more of this
madness
scholar quits we won't call it quits
we call it the start
Egypt a land of mystery intriguing and
Rich history
but do we have resorts to afterlife a
world of mummies under the Earth
[Music]
a royal wedding ring
just the man the man who took the ring
the only way to get it back is to go to
the world of the living
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh look we can use a human champions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]